bonjour ma très chers amis bonjour
bonjour mais silly stuff je suis qu'est
ce qui lui prend aujourd'hui je n'ai
jamais vu aussi préfère mon très cher
françois
bonjour monsieur 10 nov c'est un plaisir
de vous voir
auriez vous un casque colonial mais
puisque vous voulez faire de casse que
colony arrête de bavardages je suis très
pressé je n'ai pas de temps à perdre dit
moi si oui ou non vous pouvez me prêter
un casque qu'on n' ya rien on attend
d'ici si oui il m'en reste injustement
dans une vieille malle de déclassifier
toujours merci je ne parle pas plus tard
je vous salue julie tu as entendu notre
conversation
oui c'était trop ma peine dit bonjour ah
bon mais j'ai jamais vu comme ça
il est peut-être préoccupé par la
création d'une nouvelle sculpture il en
fait beaucoup c'était à mon temps bonfoh
julie tu peux me dire ce que casque
colonial d'affaires dans la conception
d'une sculpture moderne il travaille
peut-être au soleil il a peut-être perdu
d'un seul acte mais mais si l'histoire
d'alice ont chaque coup donc aujourd'hui
le soleil ne tape pas si fort que ça
pour toi et julia gens là il vient pas
vous raconter avant que se passe-t-il
alors qu'elle servait pour qui je viens
de rencontrer monsieur du stade ben ça
alors comment as-tu deviner n'était pas
difficile il vient de sortir d'ici ils
ont casimir du n'a pas trouvé bizarre
bizarre
je les ai même trouvé complètement
dingos avons qu'est ce qui t'a dit il
m'a demandé si j'avais des gants de
l'aisne à lui prêter c'est en laine et
et que lui at on répondu j'en riais
tellement qu'il est parti on sent les
épaules mais qu'est ce qui te faisait
tellement ri julie regarde ma main et
c'est d'imaginer monsieur du noir en
train de danser les fringants aussi gros
que maman s adresse est vrai que je veux
dire que je n'y avais pas position et
bien moi j'aurais pensé c'est pas une
question que j'ai posée
howie b 3 tu es très intelligent mais
non ce n'est pas ça mais je me suis
souvenu du jour où pendant une demi
heure
j'ai essayé d'en finir un gant de laine
comme avait prêté le factor oui mais moi
ce qui me chiffonne
c'est pourquoi monsieur du snop veut une
paire de gants de laine comme s'il avait
peur d'avoir froid et un casque colonial
comme s'il avait peur d'avoir chaud des
garde corps à niamey les rives là mes
très chers amis à paroles casque
colonial crâne prêter françois mais en
faire ce pacte a trouvé des gangs
l'aisne oui notre cher un acteur man a
prêté une paire elle était un petit peu
déformé comme si quelqu'un avec une main
énorme avait voulu les amphis les
syriens les revenons à l'objet de ma
visite je suis venu vous dire au revoir
pourquoi mais vous partez en voyage oui
par le prochain bateau un grand voyage
oui je vais visiter tous les pays du
monde entier et c'est un très long
voyage ça monsieur du snob en quel
honneur et où pris cette décision
et bien voilà j'ai pensé que l'île aux
enfants pouvaient avoir un ambassadeur
qui pourrait partir en visite dans tous
les pays du monde entier
vous savez comme il est important pour
chaque pays d'entretenir des relations
amicales avec les autres pays mais c'est
évident
il veut donc un ambassadeur c'est à dire
un homme ou bien est ce un monsieur du
tabac pardonnez moi je sers amis vous
avez tout à fait raison je dis donc il
faut un homme ou une femme dont
l'intelligence et la finesse sur les
qualités de coeur la prestance lui
permettent deux d'être admis
immédiatement par les gens de haute
qualité qui gouvernent les pays du monde
entier
j'ai cherché dans l'île aux enfants la
personne nous qu'ils pouvaient réunir
ses qualités ce fut lent et pénible
jusqu'au jour où faisant ma toilette
matinale je découvris dans la la glace
au dessus de mon lavabo la figure de
l'oiseau rare a trait à dire moi on est
monsieur du snav un oiseau aussi rares
vous auriez tout de suite du l'enfermer
dans une cage
tu oublies que tu pas à l'ambassadeur de
l'île aux enfants on est bien monsieur
l'ambassadeur de l'île aux enfants
yat-il encore autre chose que nous
puissions faire pour vous avant votre
départ
oui très volontiers
très chers amis pour ils vont me
procurer 200 g de galettes bretonnes et
100 grammes de ces délicieux caramels
mous que j'aime tant je vous prépare ça
tout de suite je vous remercie françois
g un service à vous tous et ses cheveux
grand plaisir et que chaque fois qu'on a
vu dans un pays il est important d'être
bien habillé les rives c'est certain oui
mais voilà je vous expliquais mon
problème voilà vous savez que je
visitais des pays où il va faire chaud
les dp ou la faire froid
oui et je voudrais être certain de ne
pas nous tromper
vous comprenez aussi je vous ai amené la
liste des pays que je dois visiter
enfin ça il faudrait que vous maîtrisiez
s'ils sont des pays chauds ou des pays
froids céder ce n'est pas pour les
enfants
ah bah c'est à dire que je ne voudrais
pas que tout le monde soit au courant
vous comprenez c'est tellement gêne ou
un rêve vous avez entendu monsieur du
snob ne connaît pas les pêcheurs et les
pays froids
elle est bien bonne eh bien je crois
monsieur les snobs que tout le monde est
au courant
alors maintenant nous pouvons peut-être
appeler les enfants un peu le relais les
enfants venez venez vite monsieur du
synode a besoin de vous installez-vous
sur le borgne vrai ce qui se passe les
enfants monsieur 10,9 en qualité
d'ambassadeur de l'île aux enfants doit
visiter un certain nombre de pays mais
il ne connaît pas les pays froids et les
pays chauds voulait bien les désaccords
bien alors premier pays qu'il doit
visiter monsieur le snobe le sénégal
sous le sénégal pays chauds la sibérie
froid l'équateur chouchou under chaud la
laponie froid froid la terre adélie
source ou froid la terra des lits froids
le tchad souffle chaud le groland trois
fois très bien le mexique sur joppich au
chaud le zaïre
chaud chaud évidemment la norvège
froid chaud froid froid l'egypte se joue
le nicaragua show la finlande of 3 je
crois l'algérie chou chaud et l'islande
l'islande froid très bien les enfants
merci beaucoup et bien voilà je vous
remercie tous je peux partir
voilà monsieur 10,9 pour petits gâteaux
et bonbons à je remercie infiniment
yat il encore je viens d'avoir trouvé le
livre des lois de l'île aux enfants
voilà ce qui est écrit écoutez seuls les
enfants elle et casimir us pourront être
des ambassadeurs de l'île aux enfants
que dis tu sais tu écris mais il a
raison si vous regardez regardez c'est
écrit effectivement d'ailleurs ne
sommes-nous pas sur l'île et casimir us
et des enfants de plus on ne peut pas
nommer comme ambassadeur quelqu'un qui
ne connaît pas les pays chauds et les
pays froids
je préfère me retirer c'est ça et bien
casimir nos vieux nous tenons nouvel
ambassadeur de l'île aux enfants
vous êtes d'accord les enfants tout le
monde est d'accord félicitations kazimi
merci merci françois joly vrai que poser
une petite question je t'écoute mauger
casimir
c'est à propos des pays chauds et des
pays froids
il est vrai que monsieur de snowboard de
les connaître oui enfin
justement je voulais te demander si tu
ne pourrais pas recommencer le jeu que
tu as fait tout à l'heure on va
commencer le
[Musique]